ja und diese Explosionen in Kiew sind
sie nun ein Vergeltungsschlag der Russen
fakt ist jedenfalls Russland macht die
Ukraine für die Explosionen auf der für
Russland strategisch wichtigen
krimbrücke verantwortlich
Hochkonjunktur für die
krim-propagandisten
seit diesem Wochenende fordern sie Rache
für diese Explosion
sie erschütterte die 19 km lange
krimbrücke seit 2014 verbindet diese
Russland und die von Moskau
völkerrechtswidrig annektierte Krim
am Samstagmorgen dann das für Putin
steht fest es ist ein Akt des Terrors es
gibt kein Zweifel daran dass das ein
Terroranschlag war der auf die
Zerstörung wichtiger ziviler
Infrastruktur der Russischen Föderation
abzielte die Auftraggeber die Täter sind
die Geheimdienste der Ukraine
was war passiert am frühen Samstagmorgen
bricht ein Brand auf der krimbrücke aus
Videos zeigen Explosionen und Meter hohe
Flammen in den Himmel
brennende Zugwaggons auf dem Gleisstück
sind zu sehen auch die Fahrbahn auf dem
Straßenteil ist massiv beschädigt
an drei Stellen stürzt die Brücke sogar
ein
der Verkehr eingestellt Moskau vermeldet
später drei Tote
laut russischen Angaben war eine
lkw-bombe explodiert
siebeneinhalb Monate nach Beginn des
russischen angriffskriegs gegen die
Ukraine wird das strategisch und
symbolisch wichtige Herzensprojekt von
Putin schwer beschädigt ein
unglaublicher Reizfaktor
während Diktator Putin den ukrainischen
Geheimdienst SBU für die Explosion
verantwortlich macht hält sich silensky
bedeckt
heute war ein guter und überwiegend
sonniger Tag im größten Teil des
Territoriums weist 20 Grad warm und
sonnig nur war es auf der Krim leider
wolkig aber auch warm aber wie wolkig es
auch ist Ukrainer wissen was zu tun ist
und Sie wissen dass unsere Zukunft
sonnig ist das ist die Zukunft ohne
Invasoren in unserem gesamten Gebiet
insbesondere auf der Krimi
fakt ist wer auch immer hinter dem
teilweisen Einsturz der krimbrücke steht
er setzt Kriegsherrn Putin mächtig unter
Druck
[Musik]